Danny Cipriani has posted an emotional
tribute to his ex-girlfriend Caroline
Flack and says the TV presenter was
killed by embarrassment and shame they
dated briefly last year and the rugby
star said he shared many intimate issues
with flag as she made him feel safe in a
video posted on Instagram where he
discussed his own mental health problems
Cipriani said he'd been in regular
contact with flack over the last three
to four months and she'd tried to
contact him in the hours before her
death so someone that I loved as a
person very Dillian so I'm very close to
has decided to take her own life at
everyone knows and I've been speaking to
her for the last 3-4 months so we've
always been in contact since we were
together since we weren't and it's
always been a loving friendship and I
was so vulnerable with her in my moment
when we first met and I told her
everything about me because I felt safe
with her so I told her all the things
that I was embarrassed and shame shame
shame feel about she made me feel okay
and ultimately it was embarrassment in
shame that killed her and we had spoken
about how things had to change I didn't
know it was going to take this
our correspondent in Salaam Rashid is
here a very emotional Danny Cipriani
they're talking about the death of
Caroline Flack his ex-girlfriend and
close friend still up until the point of
her death when she had tried to contact
him just a matter of hours before yeah
that's right look this was a very raw
emotional 18 minute video that he posted
on Instagram earlier today and clearly
unscripted he went on talking about his
relationship with Caroline Flack and it
was a short relationship that they had
but their friendship continued right up
until the point of her death last
Saturday and he also spoke a bit about
his past mental health struggles and and
and how he had to look in the face of
potentially attempting suicide at one
point as well Sarah this was a video
post on his Instagram account he's got
over 200,000 followers and he revealed
that he'd been speaking to Caroline
Flack for the past three or four months
and she actually tried to contact Danny
Cipriani last Friday night just hours
before she actually took her own life
now he said that he felt incredibly safe
sharing everything with Caroline Flack
he claimed that it was ultimately
embarrassment and shame that led to her
killing herself now he said that he
couldn't take a call from her because he
was playing rugby and that she left him
a voice message as well and he also said
that he Caroline Flack actually left him
a voice note just a couple of weeks ago
and he said that he would release that
voice note so that everyone can hear the
struggles that she was going through now
he described Caroline Flack as someone
who was so kind so beautiful she never
was malicious and that she actually
contacted him on Friday night but he
couldn't get in touch with her because
he was busy playing rugby now he goes
back to his time of struggling through
mental health and talks a bit about how
now there needs to be more kindness in
the world that he wasn't putting all the
blame
on media as there has been a lot of
speculation he wasn't putting all the
blame on the CPS there's been
speculation around how they've handled a
case of Caroline Flack as well he was
just saying to people that we need to be
more kind and those were some of the
words of Caroline Flack one of her last
Instagram posts before she killed
herself
was talking about kindness and how there
needs to be more kindness in this world
now we know that they were in a very
short relationship but obviously their
friendship has clearly continued and
they've had back-and-forth discussions
right up until her death on Saturday but
I'm sure we'll hear more from what he
has had the relationship he has had with
Caroline Flack and especially those last
few days before she died the contact
that she had with her ex-boyfriend Danny
Cipriani who's obviously come out with
this extremely raw and quite emotional
video on Instagram today ends a thank
you and if you need to talk about how
you're feeling these Samaritans are
there to talk at any time they promise
to listen in confidence and without
judgment you can call them free on one
one six one two three or email Joe at
Samaritans
dot org